by the a global citizen I'm Justin from
real-life English where our mission is
to help you not just learn English but
to live it today we're going to do
exactly that with one of the best
funniest friend scenes ever in this
scene Chandler wrote Joey's tailor
Frankie had his pants altered for
something really crazy and unexpected
happens
pay close attention I promise that today
you will have fun learning time and by
the end of this short lesson you will
watch and understand this team without
getting lost without missing the jokes
and without subtitles our power learning
method is a simple three-step process
step 1
watch the scene with English subtitles
step 2
I'm going to teach you all the key
vocabulary idioms and Evensen they ninja
native pronunciation tips step 3 we're
going to step up our game and watch the
scene again without subtitles from a
completely new perspective for maximum
benefit download this two page power
lesson I created just to this scene by
joining the real-life English power
learning Club for free on link above or
in the information box below let's do
this hey anybody know a good tailor you
need some clothes altered no no I'm just
looking for a man to draw on me with
Chuck
don't you go see Frankie my family's
been going to him forever he did my
first suit when I was 15
no wait 16 no excuse me 15 all right
when was 1990 okay you have to stop the
q-tip when there's resistance you know I
think I was 16 I've got pants I need to
be altered no hey Chandler when you see
Frankie tell him Joey Tribbiani says
hello
he'll know what I mean you sure he's
gonna be able to crack that code
but more MORE how long do you want the
cuffs at least as long as I have the
pants
I just got back okay now we'll do your
inseam yo paisan can I talk to you for a
sec
your tailor is a very bad man if you're
like most learners even if you
understood the general idea you probably
missed a lot there
I mean spoken English natives tend to
connect their words we cut them and
reduce something we use tons of idioms
humor we break the rules and strange and
surprising ways which I will show you in
a moment okay now we've got some serious
learning to do so let's focus close all
the windows in your computer remove all
abstractions grab a pen and paper even
better
download the free PDF and mp3 for this
lesson like above now for step two I'm
going to guide you through the first
page of this real-life English power
lesson your job pay attention study
learn absorb the material and step up
your game for totally new experience of
this awesome team
oh yeah anybody know a good tailor a
tailor is somebody who repairs or alters
clothes professionally he need some
clothes altered to alter clothe this is
to make changes
also notice the surprising pronunciation
of clothes he need some clothes altered
he need some clothes altered natives
take shortcuts with pronunciation with
this word and we usually say clothes
instead of pronouncing th with clothes
I'm just looking for a man to draw on me
with chalk to draw us to make a picture
in chalk it's what we use to write on a
chalkboard
Chandler's joke refers to the fact that
the tailor uses chalk to measure pants
anybody know a good tailor you need some
clothes altered native speakers often
violate grammar rules and conversational
English both informal and formal we omit
certain words to make communication
easier and more fluid notice that Joey o
omits the do in this sentence you need
some clothes altered you need some
clothes off
also did this in the first slide anybody
know a good tailor anybody know a good
tailor don't you go see Frankie my
family's been going to him forever I
went to give you a second to listen and
then imitate Joey you go see Frank
see Frank
my family's been going to him forever my
family's been going to him for that
my family's been going to him forever
here we have two excellent examples of
connected speech Joey reducing cutting
and connecting words
why don't you becomes why don't you and
going to hem becomes going to him while
natives don't write this way it is
common in normal everyday conversation
if you're a member of the real-life
power learning club in addition to the
PDF we also offer an mp3 vocabulary and
pronunciation review of this scene that
will give you more repetition and
practice you did my first suit when I
was 15 no wait 16 no excuse me 15 all
right when was 1990 suit is a formal
piece of clothing for business or nicer
occasions the joke about Joey's age is
Joey's simple obsessive confusion about
an irrelevant fact okay you have to stop
the q-tip when there's resistance here's
a q-tip also known as a cotton swab
Chandler is saying that Joey needs to be
more careful with q-tips that he's
causing brain damage by pushing the
q-tip too deep into his ear okay you
have to stop the q-tip when there's
resistance I've got pants I need to be
altered nope hey Chandler when you see
Frankie tell Joey Tribbiani says hello
you know what I mean you sure he's gonna
be able to crack that code the humor
here is that Joey acts as if he wants to
communicate an encoded message and
Chandler makes fun of him with his
typical ironic humor with a common
expression crack the code to crack means
to break and the code is a cryptic
barrier to entrance so crack the code is
to decipher a cryptic or hidden message
now when you see Frankie tell George for
the eye he says hello you'll know what I
mean you sure he's gonna be able to
crack that code how long do you want the
cuffs now at least as long as I have the
pants
Frankie is asking Chandler the length of
the cuffs cuffs can be on your ankles or
on your wrists not to be confused with
handcuffs another more subtle joke in
response to Frankie's question how long
do you want the cuffs Chandler says at
least as long as I have the pants the
humor is the how long can be used for
both the physical length of something or
for the length of time when Frankie asks
how long do you want the cuffs he's
asking about the length but Chandler's
humorous response at least as long as I
have the pants refers to the duration of
time that he will have the pants I just
got that now we'll do your inseam here's
the end sim yo paisan can I talk to you
for a sec your tailor is a very bad man
Pisan is an italian-american slang
expression for friend or buddy but this
is not commonly used and a sec is an
informal way to say a second I know that
was a lot of information but just relax
you don't need to learn it all at once
remember it's a process and you can
repeat as many times as you need
the most important thing to take into
account is that you need to make it a
fun natural system part of your everyday
life now for the third and final step
let's connect all the dots and take it
to an entirely new level we're going to
watch and enjoy the scene we just
studied one more time plus the end in
which we have not watched yet but it is
included in this power lesson PDF and
mp3 on the link below or above so now
that you learned it let's live it hey
anybody know a good tailor you need some
clothes altered no no I'm just looking
for a man to draw on me with chalk don't
you go see Frankie my family's been
going to him forever
he did my first suit when I was 15 no
wait 16 no excuse me
15 all right when was 1990 okay you have
to stop the q-tip when there's
resistance
you know I think I was 16 I've got pants
I need to be altered no hey Chandler
when you see Frankie tell him Joey
Tribbiani says hello you'll know what I
mean you sure he's gonna be able to
crack that code how long do you want the
cuffs yeah at least as long as I have
the pants
I just got that okay now we'll do your
inseam yo paisan can I talk to you for a
sec your tailor is a very bad man
Frankie what are you talking about
hey what's going on
Joey's tailor took advantage of me what
no way I've been going to the guy for 12
years oh come on you said he was gonna
do my inseam then he ran his hand up my
leg and then there was definite what
cupping that's how they do pants plus
they go up one side they move it over
then they go up the other side they move
it back and then they do the rear what
Ross we tell isn't that how a tailor
measures pants yes yes it is in prison
what's the matter with you what
that's not oh my god hey when the doctor
does that hernia test that's okay
no I swear to god dad that's not how
they measure pants we really appreciate
you watching and supporting us if you
enjoyed this lesson I would like to
invite you to support overdoing by
taking one more step to help us spread
the word first of all if you like this
video please share your thoughts
feedback or suggestions for other scenes
and comments below we'd love to hear
from you and we respond to every single
comment for second you can subscribe to
our YouTube channel or even if you
haven't already to join power learning
club with all the awesome presence we
offer exclusively to our students or
finally if you really love we're doing
feel free to share these lessons with
your English speaking and learning
friends and students thank you so much
and have an awesome day oh yeah
be this like
good job